these are people traffickers in the
English Channel and making an early
start
it is Dawn off the coast of northern
France and they're making their first
pickups of the day
what you're seeing is something new a
fresh tactic to evade a rest and make
money a taxi Boat Service
the Smugglers Meander along the
shoreline staring them down from the
beach are lines of French police but
they're not authorized to enter the
water
and in the middle dozens of migrants
crashing into the sea desperate to grab
a spotter board
it is chaotic and turbulent
on the sand the outnumbered authorities
can only try to chase people away from
the approaching boat but their efforts
are unsuccessful
the migrants plead with traffickers to
get closer to them and soon enough there
are no more spaces left on this ride to
Britain
it's mainly men but we do see a few
women and a handful of small children
and it's dangerous it's cold and Bleak
on the water and there are no life
jackets included in this Fair
the boats head off they're overloaded
the motors are struggling they need to
drop some weight if they're going to
make it
and the solution is brutally heartless
people jettisoned
we spot three men in the icy waters they
need urgent help
hypothermia has set in they can't swim
anymore
our Skipper Olivier knows the dangers
here
the men are dragged safely onto the deck
but they need medical attention fast
once on board they're taken back to the
porting Calais for treatment hopes of
reaching Britain dashed at least for
today
in the earlier hours more boats had
crossed the channel
several of them closely monitored by
French border patrols but maritime law
prevents them from intercepting unless
those on board say they're in distress
those are restrictions that cause a
moral dilemma for many people involved a
um
the British and French governments are
trying to thwart these Crossings but as
the rules of the game change so the
risks get higher
and as winter sets in the number of
people crossing shows little sign of
slowing as these Waters get colder and
more treacherous the danger will grow